check our sponsors and nature's blend
they specialize in premium Ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sun now the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam ten for ten I
[Music]
said I wanna come what happened to any
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to my channel hope
you guys are well inshallah today we're
gonna be reacting to an expo next
actress inshallah and apparently she
must be someone really popular to be on
BBC and so we're going to be talking
about we're gonna mention her name there
might be people who are pumpin over peas
gonna go watch all those you are not
watching going to be curious and all
yourself watch this disgusting why thing
that's destroying people's souls and
lives and we did another video about the
five dangers of but not really but you
can go watch let's get straight to each
other and let's hear from so by step how
did the girl who was brought by her
parents the United States from Lebanon
your home country schooled in the United
States clearly smart went to university
in Texas read history how did you get
involved with the sex porn industry
I don't think low self-esteem
discriminates against anyone doesn't
matter if you come from a great family
or if you come from a not-so-great
background I struggled my entire
childhood with weight and I never felt
attractive or worthy of male attention
we knew did you guys hear that she was
overweight and she struggled with
getting male attention these are two
things that our society puts pressure on
females and woman have me to feel more
ugly and uglier and that's what they
need to dress a certain way or dress to
impress
and this is really sad now she is meter
foolish she needs male attention because
a society everyone suffers sadly our
sister is suffering from that as well
our sisters were taken off the hedge I
have shown pass so that hijab you know
getting the hair covered but everything
below is showing and we've seen with men
you don't have to look a certain way etc
you know walking around topless and she
felt the need to have male attention
that wasn't normal yes you want to get
more attention that's what it's about
and sadly what this results in is that a
lot of people fall into you know Xena
and doing certain apps on their
boyfriends or someone that they want to
be with or supposedly wanting to marry
because they fear often losing him I
have to do this you know if I don't you
go and this is a sad reality because it
shows that you don't have to walk on
another panatela and this is what she
suffered from and this leads to a bigger
problem suddenly my first year of
college I start losing all this weight
from making small changes and by the
time I graduated I was ready to make a
bigger difference I felt extremely
self-conscious about my breasts because
that was the first thing to go when I
lost all the weight I lost about fifty
pounds I don't know how many kilos that
is or stones um well it's a considerable
amount of weight yeah changed changed
you physically completely so my biggest
insecurity was my breasts so I wanted to
more or less go back to what they
normally were and once I did that I
started garnering all this attention
from men and okay so now what she does
is she starts working on her assets and
yeah once she works on them and I don't
know plastics very well it maybe she's
talking about
then the male attention came yeah then
men were attracted to you now but the
thing I love females don't understand is
they aren't going to be attracted to you
definitely but why are they attracted to
you what do they want for you from you
you as a person your character what you
have to offer more than your body parts
or your body parts
I was never used to it and I felt like
unless I held onto it and kind of did
what was asked of me or what was
expected of me it would go away and
after feeling what it was like that
validation and you know the compliments
for the first time I did not want that
to go away no that's an addiction
now you're getting compliments you're
getting attention that is making you
happy you don't want that to go away no
now she said and what did she do to
preserve them hmm you were spotted I
think on a sermon there you were you
were a young graduate wanting to sort of
find a job and you were spotted on the
street by a guy who said I I can work
with you and clearly it's the problem
business what was it in you that far
from running away it was it was drawn
into it oh it wasn't that's not how it
was it wasn't just hey do you want to
come to you poor and it was more so oh
you're beautiful
would you like to do some modeling you
see Shaitan doesn't really come to you
with hey do you want a pen or with your
hey you want to come his [ __ ] yeah you
know it's a gradual step and she don't
take what he wants from you you know if
he tries to come to a ship you know you
don't even work his way up to ship or a
starship it's not [ __ ] innovation
innovation major sense condom agency
okay do you mind since it's not mind
since I came to do the lesser of two
good deeds it's not all keeping busy
with things are permissible etc and this
how Shaitaan comes to you will be the
company to compensate pornography to
come to know yeah you have a great body
like I think you'd be great nude
modeling things like that and after I
came in toward the studio you know it
was very respectable it was a gorgeous
location it was in Miami in Doral
Florida it was clean everyone who worked
there was nice all of their cubicles
were decorating Sam
we photos like it was nothing dodgy or
made that me just so you see in that
home yeah I'm comfortable and after do I
get the first time I went in wasn't the
first time I I filmed a porn movie it
was the second time the first time was
more so do you want to do this like sign
the paperwork etc etc so these guys they
just this is why it's so important you
know with these kind of things to have a
male guardian now you guys are thinking
oh are you saying that we woman you know
we can't make our own decisions etc I'm
not saying that because there's a lot of
woman in the chains of hadith maybe 120
who narrated Eve and a lot of different
things in but certain things you see the
male is there's your protector as a man
your husband or being your father or
your bond because these are people that
care about you these will don't know
harm but start sending the feministic
movement has made it seem like we're
independent and we can do it done yes
that's why it's fundamental brothers and
sisters but even one getting to know
somebody
one he is fundamental you know if you
don't have that in your life you can be
easily persuaded to a lot of stuff you
know there's a money machine absolutely
but you still have no advisors you have
no lawyer you have no nothing so I was
21 year old has a lawyer on retainer I'm
just trying to get my head around how
stressful this must have been and
whether even now because you see it is
so poised and obviously a lot of time
has passed and you've moved on but do
you think there is some sort of
post-traumatic stress that is in you
from this experience yes and I think it
kicks in mostly when I go out in public
because the stairs I get I feel like
people can see through my clothes and it
brings me Wow
Wow when she's out in public she feels
like people gotta see through her yeah
because she's out there and now she's
let me live the rest of her life people
knowing what she was doing her marital
relationship marrying somebody knowing
that your wife was doing all these
things with God knows how many men and
how they were violating her be it's God
knows what and that could be very
disturbing to a man very very disturbing
to a man and she's going to live the
rest of our life Linda and she admits
that and it brings me deep shame it
makes me feel like it makes me feel like
I lost all right to my privacy which I
did because I I'm one Google search away
yeah those images you cannot expunge you
have no right even though it is deeply
personal to you you have no right to
remove them from anybody's view around
the world
in the magic you feel that you look
grouped that's just she got burned she
got used and abused and she's grown that
she has no rest of it yeah it is very
hard and I'm just thinking this isn't I
mean the story is your story but frankly
it's also the story of other porn actors
and actresses I honestly started seeing
that recently after the interview came
out and people started reaching out and
all of the emails go when my manager
checks them and when he gets stuff like
that he filters them and sends them to
me and reading the words of some of
these girls who have been sex trafficked
and forced into porn and all of these
stories of girls whose lives have been
ruined by oh and by men who have taken
advantage of them and by contracts that
they didn't even didn't even understand
the jargon of it makes me feel like okay
maybe maybe it was good that I started
talking and then I posted this interview
and that I'm speaking out now because
there people feel the same way and even
if they don't relate on as deep a level
as you know doing porn they can relate
on the level of being insecure and being
pressured into doing something while you
were wearing the Islamic headscarf often
known as their job and of course then it
developed into a sex scene well you must
have known how provocative that was Wow
they got her to dress up as a hijab'
it's a new page verbatim told them you
guys are gonna get me killed and they
said they just laughed
cuz I don't give a damn about you cuz
they don't care about you you are
nothing but a money making tool sadly
did it why didn't you then say I'm not
doing it
intimidation I was scared great I I knew
that if I said no to certain feminists
you know she's like you know somebody
who's a career woman who goes out there
and you know gets it and you know I do
not know what to say man
what we've made society what we've made
females degraded them to such a level
unbelievable and then corner you know
the the in like you know Western values
it's okay you know it's alright it would
it would you know they're not you could
think of they're not gonna force you to
do it that's at that point that's rape
no one's going to force you to have sex
but I was still scared I mean I have you
ever felt scared - not scared but
nervous to speak up and say something at
a restaurant when your foods not right
and the waiter comes by and says how is
everything I I was intimidated I was
nervous
we need to do a lot of people and many
of them are middle-aged or older is
going to have somebody in the studio at
only 26 years old there is a a school of
thought which says that that our culture
as a whole lot of understood about the
United States or the UK but in many many
countries is being pornified
and that young people in particular are
so exposed to pornography so young in
their lives that it's it's materially
changing the way males and females
relate to each other the way they think
about relationships in a potentially
very corrosive damaging way exactly
women are seen as nothing but excuse my
language she's just some kind of a [ __ ]
that I'm just going to use for my sexual
desires subconsciously or subconscious
level a lot of men think like that and
lots of men look at their partners as
somebody that's just an animal you're
just an animal that is there for my
desires that I'm going to use I'm gonna
treat you on as well you know even an
intimacy certain words phrases hits
abuse is being used why because that's
what they're watching and that's what
they want to do because just watching
this not enough what's your take on that
of course it affects relationships and
porn addiction is very prevalent in
America and I'm sure here too the things
that men see in videos they expect from
the women in their lives and that's just
not reality no one is going to be that
perfect no one is going to do those acts
on a Wednesday night with the person
they love guys what else can be said
from somebody that's been in this vile
disgusting industry and I've seen for
their self I don't know what else I can
say absolutely disgusting
so violating life destroyed and people
of thousands are addicted to this and
you can see that how is destroying life
and I was discussing another video five
dangers of pornography guys you heard it
for yourself I had to blur her face
just in case it could be fit not to
Brahmas watching etc and that's what I'm
gonna say there's nothing else I can
really say it's it's it's it's so sad
it's so sad I don't know what to say I
hope you guys have listened and heard
please stay away from this vile
disgusting disease ask Thomas Capano
hotel from help take measures gradual
steps and processes and stay away from
it because this is going to violate your
soul cannot Rafi is a vile thing and it
would destroy you so till next time
Salam alaikum